tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo video
sono fa vigente ai ragazzi l'ultima
volta non me ne frega un cazzo che mar
lombardo sta giocando a space work
dovete morire
l'ultima volta che ci ho giocato ragazzi
sono riuscito a fare quattro le quattro
livelli ma non erano tre scusate tre
livelli sono riusciti a fare tra livelli
non episodio solo cosa impossibile
credo che in questo non riuscivo neanche
a partire però ci si prova vai tentativo
one non prendermi proprio alla lettera
magari fame di fare due metri allora
abbiamo capito che sto gioco è difficile
questo già lo sapevamo
il problema è che non madonna qua quanto
è difficile santo dio quanto la veloce
ma non andavano così veloce gli altri
livelli ragazzi che in realtà ragazzi
gli altri livelli che erano
incasinatissimo erano verdi c'erano
targati col verde che significa che sono
semplici semplici sto cazzo questo
ragazzi è targato arancione che dovrebbe
essere più difficile degli altri e sta
minkia e i rossi come diavolo sono
spiegate me lo devo stare zitto quando
di queste cose processo editori in
teoria sto andando bene porca [ __ ] 35
o nel male come inizio pensavo peggio
posso facciamo solo fatta no sì no sì
cosa cazzo
se io non stavo cliccando niente questa
andava storto a un certo punto non ha
capito più cazzone anche il gioco
secondo me ok siete scemi c'avete la
droga nel cervello consistono lo andava
a destra e cos'è una tangenziale
quell'anno spiegatemelo stand o ma
mettete dei cartelli almeno come cazzo
faccio io sapere che c'è una strada a
destra e mi fai fare mi vai cliccato
christie hanno cliccato che cazzo vuoi
perfetto ragazzi mi sono rotto i
[ __ ] andiamo a fare altre cose
questo è un gioco porca eva cos'era una
roba di prima cosa ci offre questa
meraviglia del panorama videoludico
questo è un gioco porca eva cosa guarda
lì il violento di è più il sor
ma perché ho fatto da adeguare questo è
un gioco di hello kitty è semplice e
morire tutti sotto un treno
c'è perché perché perché devono fare dei
giochi di me anche quelli di hello kitty
ma perché ci giocano i bambini
fatelo semplice ci gioca anche fa vj che
magari fa più schifo dei bambini sono
morto a snake si muore se colpisci il
bordeaux o settimane da solo come cazzo
sono morto qua spiega meno sono in crisi
videoludica ragazzi giochi faccin o per
bambini più seme giochi per bambini di 8
anni anni facili facili giochi per
bambini dai 2 ai 10 anni o fino sauri
extra che però car ci voleva tanto qual
è la parola più lunga della lingua
italiana
non lo so però deve morire la famiglia
su player game store che questo questo è
un gioco semplice per bambini di otto
anni dai 2 agli 8 anni quindi otto anni
massimo out for the bike come ci arrivo
la su come se come ci arrivo ragazzi
come ciao
perché oggi non riesco a giocare un
cazzo ah ok lo nuovo con usd
ho capito che a quello grosso non può
camminare sull'acqua quello grosso non è
gesù adesso puoi affetto perfetto
portare anche l'altro fantastico come
minchia l'aborto ok bravo dai cazzo dai
che sei arrivato a valorizzare lo stato
ok come fossero un gioco per bambini di
otto anni non è così semplice cazzo vai
vai va grandissimo ma fermo no no no no
va a 3 a pelo giorno i giochi di oggi
sono una merda una merda porca eva non
riescono a fare dei videogiochi che
siano video giochi per bambini ci ha
scritto per bambini il videogioco più
facile no questo non è un cazzo fa ma
siete scemi no no deve morirvi la
famiglia facciamo una bella cosa
passiamo già metri da jacques ior da
ragazzi siamo su geometri lasci come se
non bastasse pro g
e provo a fare prova a fare più schifo
di quanto non riesca a farlo già di mio
a parte io che faccio schifo a giocare
non è così difficile credo che per il
nostro livello mica perché perché c'è un
countdown cosa succede 17 18 che sotto
in teoria il countdown si fa il
contrario ma perché cesto countdown
qual è il problema i fatti gli auguri di
compleanno alla fine non mi fate gli
auguri visto gran cazzo perché 20
ragazzi sta roba è flipboard su chomet
rilascio editoria e quello non è la
stessa cosa è che giocare a flachi bird
ok
ok ok ok ok ok ok va 30 31 caccia è
veramente fra più verde un po più
difficile di platì porca [ __ ] non ci
arriverò mai alla fine ci sarà qualcosa
che riuscirò a fare tranquilli chi c'è
c'è lo so io un livello medio 11 decente
non non troppo difficile non troppo
impossibile credo che sia superiore ai
giochi per bambini dai 28 anni e credo
non ne sono sicurissimo
invece forse si regga grazie di avermi
indicato dove devo andare no perché ci
avevo molta scelta nella direzione
grazie concludono non cazzo sapevo lo
sapevo sbagliato a cliccare è il gioco
più difficile che avete mai giocato
nella vostra vita non voglio saperlo
serio re che se me lo dite potrei
pensare 10
sto scherzando siamo siamo arrivati
quasi alla fine che probabilmente mi
viene un infarto dai c'è una fine a sto
gioco per l'amor di dio
credo di sì credo che siamo arrivati
credo di sì
niente dalla vita niente porca eva
niente e non si riesce a giocare un
cazzo belliche così riesco che problemi
ci hai solo così riesco spiegatemelo no
voglio capire credo di essermi
ufficialmente spaccato una mano nel
dargli alla tastiera non mi sento un
dolore indescrivibile ragazzi perché
devo sfogare in qualche modo la mia
rabbia repressa quindi o lancio delle
cose contro i vetri era morto qua che ne
so io quindi trasformi supposta dimmelo
limiti sto per trasformare in supposta
così ti infilo tutto nel cu by vai vai
vai vai che un livello oggi lo finiamo
che vai vai vai se se se se
addio così stavamo a cristo
tanto gesù
grazie grazie tempo sette minuti ho
perso sette minuti della mia vita su
dorati come sette anni ragazzi sarà
riuscito a vincere una cosa per l'amor
di dio che solo a guardarlo mi viene il
voltastomaco cos'è sta roba
se io proverò a da ragazzi vi giuro ve
lo giuro che nel prossimo episodio che
faccio di geometri dash provo uno da 10
uno solo però perché non ce la farò mai
a farne di più ma già tanto se ne faccio
uno per oggi sono più che contento di
essere riuscito a finire un livello
quindi spero capito vi sia piaciuto
ragazzi io c'ho capito che grosso quanto
la mia testa sulla mano però vabbè se
video è piaciuto ma se il tracciato un
momento è un mi piace anche a pagina di
facebook e coniglio trattare iniziale 16
vediamo lo fossimo vito belle ragazze